[Musique]
à
la base j'étais sûr que c'était vous je
suis trop content de vous avoir trouvé
ben ouais vous allez bien
comment ça s'est passé pour vous quand
même on sort d'une période de
confinement successifs des couvre feux à
répétition qui sont en train de se lever
quand vous avez fait pour tenir le coup
on est partis au mexique écoute
des premiers confinement on a haussé
mythe d'un coup a cravaché énormément
pour être présente au maximum pour les
gens sur les réseaux sociaux ont
cravaché expression du 16e voilà
exactement je vais me mets dans le monde
voilà exactement a beaucoup bossé et du
coup on a pris un rythme tous les jours
on a enregistré des trucs ans et des
vidéos qu'on soit ensemble ou pas
ensemble et du coup en fait on a un peu
garder ce rythme là alors certes la
scène nous manque énormément
c'est surtout ça en fait c'est que
chaque fois on nous disait assez bon
vous allez pouvoir faire dépenser appui
du conte se projetait enfin c'est annulé
puis c'était repoussé comme tous les
artistes en vain du coup c'est vraiment
ça qui nous a manqué mais là on espère
que normalement de tournée elle et elle
sera ok en septembre ça y est avec élise
on sera au premier rang sterlin on est
lisez pas avec moi mais moi je suis ici
on est au coin du feu on s'est créé une
petite ambiance j'imagine que vous avez
peut-être envie de chanter après tout ce
temps passé le vent de voix de public
c'est moi votre public et puis c'est les
copains les copines de renversant qui
nous regardent meilleur public nous fait
quelque chose avec plaisir
j'étais moi dans l'océan gérer nourrir
les poissons faut bien mourir toute
façon si je finis sur l'autre rive jeter
entrée avec ma chanson c'était mon
erreur et du mois jusqu'au silence
balance mois en prison ou prix de moins
d'horizon c'est l'innocence est fautif
je suis coupable nous raison de nos
diables mon coeur
mon corps je le ferais chanter en choeur
encore
sauzon tapis de fleurs
mon corps pour danser des hommes
en encore
règlement commun des lois mais vois-tu
nra dida
c'est le môme d'aidé
je serai encore plus libre
tu peux me jeter la pierre me traîner
sur le béton oui j'aurais madame et on
est en moi comme l'allumage y appuyer
sur la touche qu'enfin se rallume les
étant celle d'hier soldats soulevé le
plomb fierté pour seule munition jamais
aucun de désert ne fera taire cette
chanson
encore je devrais chanter en choeur
encore sous le pied de free
[Musique]
mon corps pour danser des hommes
encore
[Musique]
le mans comme un héros
mais motul ra débat
[Musique]
ça
je serai encore plus les bras
[Musique]
le moins bonnes raisons mais me tuer les
rats débat
[Musique]
cdd
je serai encore plus libre de nos jobs
le co
en encore je le ferais chanter en choeur
encore
60 à pied de flore